oh hi internets on today's episode of
game life we're going to be talking
about Star Wars The Force Unleashed the
brand new Star Wars game that Darth
Vader I told you I don't need a co-host
wait it'll be awesome what oh hi
do not want if you've been into a book
star a toy star generally anywhere in
the last few weeks you might be asking
yourself hey when is this star wars the
force unleashed movie coming out the
answer is it's not the Force Unleashed
is Lucas Films latest attempt to create
a new chapter in the Star Wars universe
by creating all the different products
that they would make for a Star Wars
movie except without the movie so
there's novels graphic novels action
figures a pen and paper role-playing
games in the centerpiece of it all the
video game Star Wars The Force Unleashed
is a tale of a pivotal moment in the
saga the plot revolves around what
happened between the prequel trilogy and
the good movies
the gameplay description is just as
tantalizing as Darth Vader's secret
apprentice you get to roam around the
galaxy tearing up with the force
laying waste to people scenery and
jealous unfortunately Force Unleashed is
a huge letdown
the story is okay but the gameplay just
doesn't pan out in the way it's supposed
to and for something that's been in
development for so long that can be
surprisingly unpolished so here's the
deal your star killer Darth Vader was
going around wiping out all the Jedi but
decided instead to kidnap baby you and
train you in secret so you could both
wipe out the Emperor together so he's
got you going on missions killing
Imperials and Jedi alike sowing the
seeds of insurrection throughout the
game you'll learn all about how much fun
the dark side of the force can be is
you'll be levitating wookies and
throwing them off of cliffs electrifying
80 80s with that awesome finger
lightning that the emperor uses
gorgeous using your trusty evil red
lightsaber as the game progresses you'll
gain levels RPG style and be able to
earn new attacks and upgrade old ones
there's a definite sense of progress by
the end of the game you'll feel
significantly more powerful and
destructive than when you started
unfortunately I found that the shine
wore off of the force powers pretty
quickly
after the first few levels nothing
really impressed me anymore
and once you strip away that novel team
what you're left with is a thoroughly
mediocre action game come on guys it's
2008 there's no excuse anymore for a
camera system that's this terrible
you've got a constantly babysitted even
though the levels are straightforward
and linear the targeting system if the
game can be said to have a targeting
system will occasionally ignore
immediate threats and cause you to cast
Force Lightning on nearby rocks and
trees and as I said there's a surprising
lack of polish it's very rough around
the edges the Xbox 360 version which is
what we reviewed has tons of loading
time even when you die I'd have to
restart a level the game can't even
bring up its menu screens without a
loading screen in between them that the
scene transitions are choppy it just
jumps between gameplay and cinema
jarring Lee Force Unleashed is such a
rough experience that it feels like
you're playing a generic licensed movie
game sometimes and where it really truly
fails is close to the end of the game
where in what is supposed to be an
incredibly climactic scene you bring
down a giant star destroyer ship using
the force what transpires is one of the
most unbelievably frustrating and awful
sequences that I have ever played in a
video game the controls are nonsensical
the on-screen prompts lie to you Force
Unleashed would have been a
significantly better game if its
designers had just deleted this entire
scene at this point I just wanted the
game to be over and luckily it almost
was with just a couple of anticlimactic
boss fights left to do I think a lot of
people are going to want to play Force
Unleashed for the same reasons I did the
dual appeal of the interesting storyline
in the gameplay centered around force
powers well I wouldn't go so far as to
call it a bad game it is absolutely a
disappointing one I'm giving it a 5 out
of 10
you